le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
communément appelé les soldats du feu
les pompiers interviennent auprès des
populations de différentes façons tu
gros feux de forêt ou petits bobos ces
hommes et ces femmes dévouées
interviennent toujours avec la
conviction de vouloir aider et soutenir
son prochain
pour intervenir au mieux il est
nécessaire que les pompiers soient le
mieux équipé possible qu'ils disposent
des meilleures conditions de travail
comment améliorer ses conditions de
travail on en parle maintenant d'un lien
social
christian lebon et sergent-chef aux 10
de saint lô
comme ses collègues christian exerce son
métier avec beaucoup de passion l'esprit
d'équipé la solidarité et le respect des
autres font partie de ses valeurs
propres à tous les pompiers
ces hommes rencontrent chaque jour des
situations compliquées des problèmes
difficiles à résoudre malgré leur
entraînement régulier et les stages de
perfectionnement
les pompiers doivent tout de même faire
preuve d'improvisation
car chaque intervention est différente
c'est pour cette raison que le conseil
général soutient le sdiss de la réunion
en investissant entre autres dans des vs
avez véhicule de secours et d'assistance
aux victimes afin d'augmenter les
chances de sauver des réunionnais donc
il ya du matériel de nouvelles
technologies qui nous est parvenu on la
ddsv savez dispose de la climatisation
donc vraiment un confort aussi bien pour
la victime que pour nos intervenants
nous avons à des tables et des
perfusions
qui permet aussi bien aux médecins du
smur qu'à nous-mêmes de travailler dans
de meilleures conditions donc en fait le
but c'est vraiment d'optimiser
le potentiel qu'on a sur le véhicule ont
travaillé dans de très bonnes conditions
d'une pas avoir une meilleure prise en
charge est assurée aussi
la santé et la sécurité de notre
personnel
nous avons également aussi depuis acquis
de requins du matériel qui est un peu
nouveau pour nous c'est des garuda
tourniquet on a également vu des sangles
une seule a régné pour sembler une
victime lors d' accidents de la voie
publique c'est du matériel de dernière
génération donc les techniques ont été
améliorés pour qu'on soit performant et
qu'on diminue aussi ce phénomène de
stress qui est à permanent puisque
chaque intervention est différent
inattendue donc le fait d'avoir du
matériel
de qualité nous permet aussi d'être plus
se rassurent intervention alors ce qu'on
a également s'éteint
un mot encore dernière génération qui
permet pendant le transport de lier
lebron des déformations de la route vous
confondre la victime donc c'est sûr on
ressort est vraiment
nous qui avons connu lors les anciens
aves avait sourire que
la victime mais y'a rien à voir elle est
pratiquement horizontale tout sur tout
le monde de la route on a eu sur les
chemins un peu
dans les écarts ou sûr
sur des fois deux voies on est vraiment
dans les cautions team
cet équipement moderne est certes très
coûteux mais ce n'est pas du luxe il n'y
a pas de prix pour augmenter les chances
de sauver des vies la présidente du
conseil général nassimah dindar met un
point d'honneur à ce que toutes les
casernes et tous les pompiers de la
réunion puisse bénéficier du meilleur
équipement possible la sécurité des
réunionnais est très importante pour le
dit c'est aussi pour le conseil général
il faut savoir qu'il y à 3000 pompiers
aujourd'hui qui travaillent au quotidien
pour assurer cette sécurité et qu'un
pompier intervient toutes les 12 minutes
par jour c'est dire l'importance
qu'occupe dans la vie au quotidien
ces pompiers et le travail qu'il réalise
il faut leur rendre un hommage
particulier
c'est pour cela que le conseil général
nous avons mis des moyens
supplémentaires aux dix réunions en
livrons des véhicules de haut niveau
pour avoir des outils performants pour
ce travail au quotidien dix-neuf
nouveaux véhicules et jusqu'à 2017 il y
aura donc 40 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui seront budgétés pour
que nous puissions pas seulement mieux
équipés mais aussi
réhabiliter et construire de nouvelles
casernes donc vraiment des conditions de
travail optimisé pour avoir une sécurité
des réunionnais optimisé elle aussi
chaque année la démographie de la
réunion évolue le nombre d'habitants
augmente les immeubles et les routes se
multiplient ces paramètres augmente
aussi les risques d'incendié d'accident
il est donc nécessaire et indispensable
que les services des de la population
dispose du meilleur équipement possible
pour optimiser les interventions
les compétences humaines ne manque pas
de même que le dévouement et le
professionnalisme
mais chaque seconde de gagnés dans une
intervention peut sauver une victime
temps de réaction qui peut être
améliorée grâce aux nouvelles
technologies
optimiser les moyens techniques pour les
pompiers de la réunion c'est améliorer
le service aux personnes en difficulté
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais